no way that I could come up with a worst
list for this trilogy so we'll be back
next week with a brand new subject here
on top five well if he won't do it I
will
[Music]
as a general in the dino rob army it is
my job to destroy this show and its
hosts back to the future is something
your precious Walter holds near and dear
to his heart and while you all might
agree that this trilogy is nearly
flawless nothing's perfect
the glorious 1980s may have spawned this
franchise but when you really try and
break down these films they don't make
any sense plot holes inconsistencies and
paradoxes within paradoxes within
paradoxes comprise a series of movies
that are more overrated than avatar and
avatar combined you all may claim to
love these motion pictures but what you
really love is hearing the negative you
love to hear others hate after all
aren't you on this channel to watch that
other buffoon complain about movies and
TV shows that were meant for babies
sorry is this intro too long for you
enjoy the hate these are the top five
worst Back to the Future trilogy moments
number five
he's a peeping tom
Marty's father isn't just a total loser
who isn't worth saving he's also a
complete pervert they have to establish
George McFly as someone without any kind
of dump Shanor will to defend himself or
others he's a super weird and eccentric
guy we understand this but did they have
to make him a peeping tom this was set
up earlier in the movie with the McFly's
talking at the dinner table what Laurie
what the actual fact of what George was
doing before getting struck by his
father-in-law's car isn't a pleasant one
it's also not funny wouldn't it have
made George a little more sympathetic if
he was just minding his own business
reading a book or his notes not paying
attention when he's hit by the vehicle
getting picked on by Biff is one thing
but there's nothing really in George for
Marty to inspire he has to walk him
through everything and is only redeemed
because he gets mad one time and don't
get me started on how creepy Lorraine is
with a complete stranger to her in the
next scene number four
hey I don't know scram McFly Kinect
[Music]
so George overcomes his greatest fear
and finally takes out Biff but then
walks away when a soulless ginger takes
Loraine from him somatically this makes
sense you want to build tension and
suspense before the day is saved but we
just went through the biggest trial of
George's pathetic life he punched Biff
out
he saved Lorraine she obviously fell for
him in that last scene so I fail to
understand why this was needed other
than a lazy way of having a little
climax for Marty almost disappearing and
who the hell is that guy he's never
established beforehand and we never even
learned his name after Biff shouldn't
this have been a piece of cake I guess
not because George lets him take Loraine
and walks off he walks away from the
situation after a few seconds of this
guy's weird laughs George returns to
push him down and make out with his
future wife hooray I suppose couldn't
this at least have been one or more of
Biff's goons that would have made it
slightly less frustrating I prefer the
guy with the 3d glasses over Billy Zane
by the way number three
to anyone who thinks this is a perfect
trilogy I give you Clara
plate even if you like these movies
Clara sticks out like a sore thumb she
ruins a perfectly good premise in Back
to the Future Part three with her
strange delivery and annoying love plot
with Doc giving doc a love interest is
not a bad concept hell I'd venture as
far to say it's good writing that he
would find his true love outside his own
time period but Clara is just the worst
in a previous scene she dramatically
changes her mind about leaving town and
gives us this chestnut but was this man
tall with great big brown puppy-dog eyes
and long silvery flowing hair
you knew him him while on the train her
gross incompetence nearly gets everyone
killed they all do manage to escape with
their lives but she end up stranding doc
in the 1880s with no way home if it
wasn't for an awfully convenient time
train machine doc miraculously built in
the Old West he would have never seen
Marty again or even have known if he
made it back to 1985 safely Clara you
are the worst
and I think Marty agrees with me my day
but the fact that you'd expect me to
entertain a notion like that is so
insulting and degrading oh look it's
Clara again this scene just played out
all wrong and cemented Clara as the
worst character in the franchise after
some convincing from Marty doc realizes
he indeed does not belong in the Old
West and agrees to go with Marty back to
the future however he first must
confront Clara and tell her he's leaving
as they fall in love over the short
amount of time they've known each other
when doc arrives he tells her the truth
that he's a time traveler and must
return to where he came from
Clara's reaction to this is to slap him
in the face and accuse him of taking
advantage of her she totally freaks out
this scene had her come off horribly and
doc just seems like a lovesick fool
wouldn't this have been better if doc
didn't mention he was a time traveler he
just tells her he has to leave maybe
something important has come up when she
asks why he doesn't tell her and is
forced to walk away as she asks more
questions doc can shed a tear as Clara
is left helplessly confused in the
background mutually heartbroken Clara
still decides to leave
and Doc turns to a night at the bar to
subdue his depressed thoughts instead
Clara loses it in a scene that made
everyone look bad and the number one
works
Back to the Future trilogy moment is a
chicken that's it isn't nothing but a
little chicken this moment retroactive
Lee made Marty even dumber than he
already was are we really supposed to
believe that Marty would risk his entire
mission on biff calling him a chicken
come on man it was just a dumb little
plot device to give Marty a clever
weakness to get over with absolutely no
mention at all of his temper in part one
this always felt out of place every time
it was used but it is the worst here
Marty has pretty much won the day at
this point in the movie Biff challenges
him to a final fight which Marty easily
turns down and walks away from but then
just the mention of the word chicken
completely changes
Marty's full demeanor he's drawn back
into a face-to-face with Biff before the
door close to them flies open the first
film's version of Marty leaves on his
way to the Clocktower event with Doc and
in the process knocks his counterpart to
the ground it's confusing to explain but
you know what I mean
Biff then takes the Almanac and we're in
trouble all over again
the sheer stupidity of that action was
beyond ridiculous he willingly went back
into that confrontation and nearly
doomed everything yet this is supposed
to be our hero
pish-posh as bad as this trilogy was the
animated series based off of it was even
worse I believe my altruistic
doppelganger recently spoke of it on his
own
filthy channel I don't want to hear what
you think but what are some of your
least favorite back to the Future
trilogy moments how can I destroy Walter
and end this show
give me some hate mail and let me know
to keep in contact you can check me out
on myspace or follow along on xanga
where I post polls about what of Walters
maybe destroyed in the future Oh hail
our overlord Dino Rob
and his magnificent army this has been
the very last episode of top 5 hey did
you just do a top 5 horse back to the
future moments video I did I do audience
feed it bye bye top 5 how could you even
come up with five moments it's the
perfect trilogy doc Marty and Clara are
three the best characters of all time
yeah Clara really the deed is done top
five is dead and so are you
the final battle is upon us you and your
friends don't stand a chance against
Dino robbing his army all hail our
overlord
the final battle what does that mean it
means next week I'm gonna kill Dino Rob
or he's gonna kill me
[Music]
[Applause]
you